la la Thaïlande est-ce qu'elle est là
Mina on va peut-être la la voir et on va
la rejoindre Hamza est également sur ce
plateau merci d'être là Hamza je le
disais vous avez été témoin de ce qui
s'est passé en Thaïlande pour Mina la
voici bonsoir bonsoir Mina merci de de
merci de nous répondre depuis la la
Thaïlande votre histoire est à peine
croyable Mina on a vraiment été
interpellé par ce qui vous est arrivé je
résume pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
votre histoire vous êtes parti en
Thaïlande avec votre fils de de 7 ans ça
devait être des vacances merveilleuses
vous aviez énormément économisé pour ces
vacances et ça a viré au cauchemar
puisque votre fils de 7 ans s'est fait
agresser par un épicier il est revenu et
on va voir la vidéo Mina si vous le
permettez il est revenu on voit bien que
cet enfant est complètement paniqué
évidemment la mère que vous êtes votre
son n'a fait qu'un tour vous êtes allé
voir l'épicier vous l'avez collé une une
gifle et il a porté plainte contre vous
depuis vous êtes bloqué en Thaïlande
votre fils est rentré parce qu'on vous a
pris votre passeport et le Koré je les
ai appeléor pour tout vous dire min moi
je les ai appelé pour les faire réagir
sur votre histoire évidemment ils ont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de dossiers à
traiter en ce moment mais semble-t-il ne
font pas grandchose pour vous je
voudrais qu'on regarde la vidéo et après
on vous entend et on entend un regardez
cette vidéo de votre fils ça a été filmé
à à l'hôtel après
l'agression avec ses mains là il fait
comme ça avec ses mains
[Musique]
là
voilà et on vous voit repartir Mina
d'abord comment ça va
ça va le choc est
passé vous tennez le
coup c'est un peu compliqué mais bientôt
fini les Thaïlandais se bouge un peu
donc racontez-nous ce qui vous est
arrivé et et surtout les les minutes qui
qui suivent racontez-nous comment
comment ça se passe évidemment le son
votre son ne fait qu'un tour vous
retournez voir l'épicier à partir de ce
moment-là effectivement tout dégénère
racontez-nous
min alors moi quand je suis retourné à
l'épisserie j'étais 5 minutes avant il
était habillé il était en poste quand
j'y retourne en courant je le trouve
entièrement nu dans dans son
équie je demande à tout le monde
d'appeler la police et tout le monde
parlait anglais et moi je parle pas très
bien anglais il y avait Hamza qui était
là dans une chambre en haut je savais
qu'il était français donc je lui ai
demandé la police est arrivée on les a
suivi à partir de là on m'a demandé on
m'a dit directement en fait non tu as
cassé sa boutique donc faut que tu payes
c'est toi la coupable je leur ai dit
mais il s'est passé ça
euh en fait ce qui importter pour eux
c'était les dégâts
matériels Ctait ce que moi j'avais
j'avais fait après ça d'accord je
comprends effectivement votre Hamza est
avec nous sur ce sur ce plateau vous
avez assisté à la scène qu'est-ce que
vous avez vu vous Hamza euh en fait
comment s'est passé c'était en fait le
son son fils je le rencontre dans la
salle de sport qu'on a de la salle de
sport commune de l'hôtel et je
sympathise avec lui parce que il entend
que je parle français qu'on a l'autre
bout du monde et voilà donc donc après
on se liit un peu d'amitié tout ça et
puis souvent les après-midi on se capte
autour de la piscine commune de l'hôtel
tout ça donc en fait elle elle voyait de
loin comme moi je l'ai salué des fois le
matin elle voyait de loin où est-ce qu'
était ma chambre donc ce qui se passe
c'est qu' un matin elle vient toquer en
en furie à ma chambre et
complètement complètement affolé et donc
je me réveille je dis qu'est-ce qu'il y
a et tout elle me dit ils ont touché mon
fils donc moi je la suis je la suis en
courant tout ça puis on arrive en bas et
juste collé en fait à l'hôtel il y a il
y a l'épicerie tenu par un par un par un
un Thaïlandais un peu âgé soixantaine
d'années comme ça peut-être un peu moins
peut-être 55 je c et euh et du coup le
le et quand j'arrive devant l'épicerie
en fait je trouve une dizaine de
Thaïlandais autour qui essayent de
savoir un peu ce qui se passe le petit
Ilas il il est posé sur le sur le à côté
de de l'hôtel et puis Mina qui retourne
en furrié sur lui en me disant il a fait
ça il a touché mon fils donc après moi
je reprends le petit je dis dis-moi
exactement tout ce qui s'est passé tout
ça et tout et puis elle on arrivait pas
j'arrivais pas à la calmer parce qu'elle
était prise de de ce qui venait de se
passer surtout que son fils pour l'avoir
un petit peu côtoyé il est pas du genre
pour très peu l'avoir côtoyé il est pas
ouf pour pour aller raconter un truc
comme ça donc ça lu ça l'a vraiment
touché même quand il est venu dire à sa
mère il l'a d un peu timidement il m'a
touché devant après il a pris ma main il
l'a mis dans son pantalon après donc
c'était un peu elle était sûr de son
fils quoi donc ça pour elle ça la
direction
c'était ce monsieur quoi donc j'essayé
un petit peu de tempérer tout ça parce
que moi j'ai l'habitude d'aller en
Thaïlande je sais que voilà ils peuvent
parfois avoir des méthodes un peu ils
ont un peu un peu archaïque sur sur
certaines choses et du coup je me suis
dit on va pas aller on va pas faire
justice tout de suite soi-même comme ça
et tout parce que on n pas chez nous et
que le le système sur place là-bas va
faire que on va se faire voilà quoi et
elle elle a pas pu s'empêcher parce que
son fils il était traumatisé il arrivé
plus la réaction d'une mère évidemment
surtout surtout quand a vu ça surtout
quand quand il a compris parce qu'au
début il l'a gardé pour lui et dès qu'il
l'a dit à sa mère et qu'il a vu le bom
que ça a fait il a compris que c'était
encore mais mais mais Mina ce qu'on
voudrait comprendre c'est pourquoi ils
vous ont pris votre passeport parce que
votre fils traumatisé mais a pu rentrer
en France Hamza vous avez pu aussi
rentrer ouais parce que vous avz moi je
me suis ent moi je me suis enfui un peu
parce que l'étau il commença à se
resserrer ouis parce qu'on on a commencé
avec une avec la version la plus la plus
réaliste c'està dire la vraie euh elle
envoie son fils voir s'il y a pas des
clés dans la dans l'épicerie dans
laquelle il était même pas 5 minutes
avant euh son fils il revient toucher
euh jusqu'ici on peut se plaindre de ça
j'ai envie de vous dire la gifle à ce
moment-là norm les f tout de suite il y
a même pas besoin d'en parler et euh et
en fait eux là-bas ils ont beaucoup le
respect de l'ancien de ce de de de donc
ils sont pour eux c'était nous les
agresseurs les Français venus en
Thaïlande pour agresser ce monsieur sans
vraiment de vraies raisons valbl
incroyable et j'ai cru comprendre qu'il
avait des liens avec le maire ce
monsieur il avait des liens avec le
maire il avait il avait en fait ouais
bon ça marche par ça marche un peu par
clan en Thaïlande et souvent il ils ont
des petites connaissances avec certaines
personnes qui font que ça peut être
compliqué de s'attaquer à certaines
personnes même si'il en avait pas l'air
il don une peti épicerie comme ça on
dirait pas non mais ça c'est pas c'est
effectivement ça se voit pas au visage
Mina donc ça fait un mois que vous êtes
là-bas racontez-nous comment ça se passe
votre quotidien et comment vous vous
battez pour essayer de rentrer en France
et retrouver votre
fils
moi je me suis tournée d'abord vers
l'ambassade je cherchais un peu de
soutien parce que j'avais beaucoup de
rendez-vous où fallait aller chez le
procureur fallait trouver des TR sur
place j'avais pas de réponse des fois
pendant 2 TR jours après on m'a dit oui
tu es accusé tu dois déposer ton
passeport le jour où je suis allé au
tribunal je savais pas qu'on allait
m'enfermer je suis allé une journée en
prison mon fils m'a vu en fait c'était
un engronage que je comprenais pas parce
que personne m'avait
expliqué et en fait à partir du moment
où j'ai fait le tweet les Thaïlandais
ont fait en sorte que je sois plus
épaulé dans ça le monsieur il va retirer
sa plante mais je dois le payer les
dommages min il va retirer sa plainte
l'pissier mais vous vous avez porté
plainte contre lui oui moi j'ai porté
plainte contre lui ma plainte pour la
guérisson sexuelle elle reste en fait
c'est deux PL deux plaintes distinctes
moi il y a ma plainte contre lui et il y
a sa plainte à lui donc dans tous les
cas je suis accusé et c'est pour ça
qu'il m'ont retiré mon passeport quand
on est accusé de quelque chose et qu'on
est touriste en fait on vous enlève
votre passeport alors attendez Mina vous
faites comment parce que vous êtes pas
en prison mais comment vous faites pour
vivre là-bas ça coûte de l'argent vous
êtes pas vous êtes parti en Thaïlande 15
jours comment vous faites j'ai payé une
caution pour sortir de prison sinon ben
j'ai ma famille qui m'aide un peu euh
j'ai mis en place une cagnotte donc ça
m'aide un peu aussi mais je sais pas
quand est-ce que je vais pouvoir rentrer
j'attends encore et il il est où votre
fils et comment il comment va-t-il
ah non mon fils il est euh il a régressé
il a dé toc il se lave les mains 15 fois
par jour il s'est remis à faire TER au
lit là il est chez mes parents mais il
comprend pas pourquoi je suis pas là il
m'a même déjà dit j'aurais dû jamais
rien te dire ah le pauvre c'est horrible
ça Hamza vous l'avez vu vous de le fils
de ououi je l'ai vu je l'ai vu je l'ai
vu même pas fr non je l'ai vu je l'ai vu
que là-bas parce qu' après par la suite
du coup comme on a été obligé de sous
conseil des policiers thaïlandais on a
été obligé un peu de quitter notre hôtel
parce que il était apparemment pas bon
pour nous en plus de sa situation qu'on
sache où on habite euh donc on a était
obligé de déménager et du coup bah comme
on s'est retrouvé on va dire entre
guillemets dans la même salade on est
resté un peu ensemble avec le petit
essayer de lui faire faire des choses
des activités pour qu'il essaie de
penser à autre chose donc on a essayé de
faire ce qu'on a pu mais le problème
c'est que le système là-bas il fait que
tous les deux tris jours faut se
retrouver en face d'un procureur tout ça
donc le petit ça le remet à chaque fois
dedans dedans dedans donc voilà mais
voilà le le le le le le le truc il l'a
le plus touché Mina en fait c'est arrivé
là-bas c'était l'abandon en fait mais
l'abandon de qui du kedorsé vous accusez
le kéoré de ne pas avoir fait ce qu'il
Falla la vité je vais pas leur dire le
contraire pour faire plaisir moi j'ai
assisté j'étais là j'ai vu VO alors
racontez-moi c'est quoi le problème avec
le K d'oré Mina racontez-nous vous les
avez appelé vous savez ce qu'ils m'ont
dit moi le Kor parce que je les ai
appelé ils m'ont dit mais si on lui a
fourni un avocat et un traducteur est-ce
que c'est
vraiorsoc pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout je suppliais l'ambassade de me
répondre et j'ai toutes les tous les
toutes les photos proch les harcelé et
cetera donc c'està-dire vous avez pas
d'avocat vous avez pas de traducteur ils
m'ont donner une liste d'avocats qui
sont agréés par l'ambassade française je
les ai tous appelé un à un il y en a
aucun qui a voulu me prendre j' en a
peut-être trois qui m'ont répondu après
ils m'ont dit bah vous avez qu'à prendre
un comis d'office ils m'ont jamais
fourni de traducteur le moins cher pour
un traducteur ici c'est 150 € et j'ai dû
en payer 4 5 ils m'ont jamais fourni de
d'avocats ils m'ont ils m'ont jamais dit
même un soutien me dire oui n'ayez pas
peur c'est parce que au final les
Thaïlandais c'est leur procédure qu' l'
ont suivi mais me dire oui ne soit pas
attendez excusez-moi c'est quoi ça se on
voit effectivement un un mail qui
s'affiche sur sur l'écran bonjour je
suis désolée notre bureau n'aura pas le
temps de vous soutenir là-dessus
j'espère que cette sale histoire se
terminera bien à CEI vous avez un très
bon bon un avocat qui a été appelé vous
le trouverez sur Internet sans problè ça
c'est ce que vous a répondu le non sans
blague il pas vrai j'ai failli retour
écoutez vendredi dernier j'ai failli
retourner en prison parce que quand le
monsieur a a retiré sa plainte on m'a
dit oui tu dois payer pour une gifle
l'amende c'est 1000 bats moi j'avais
plus d'argent j'avais vraiment plus
d'argent donc j'avais l'argent de
l'amende j'arrive au commissariia il me
disent non enfin au tribunal il me
disent non en fait c'est 5000 Bates
d'amende l'équivalent de 180 €. je leur
ai dit mais je les ai pas il m'a dire tu
vas aller en prison c'est 500 bat de
prison par jour tu vas aller en prison
on m'a descendu dans la pièce déjà j'y
suis allée une fois je suis encore
traumatisée ça m'est jamais arrivé autre
part même en France il m'a dit bah tu
vas aller en prison et de là il y a une
une dame d'une ONG qui a appelé et qui a
fait le paiement par virement sinon
j'allais encore retourner en prison et
j'étais toute seule personne c'est
incroyable le korc ne bouge pas
l'ambassade ne fait rien Hamza juste
comment vous expliquez ça comment ça se
fait quand quand Thaïlande ça bouge pas
enfin il y a une ambassade française
pourqui en fait en fait eux les
Thaïlandais ils ont pris ça à cœur les
les les les les les les procureurs et
tout ça à la fin quand ils se sont rendu
compte que c'est une histoire quand même
qui était très sérieuse et qui s'est
fait entendre parce que c'est ça aussi
les réseaux sociaux c'est ça qui a fait
que ça s fait entendre un petit peu
partout sinon je vous dis la vérité ça
être étouffé et euh et voilà elle a fait
elle a fait ce qu'elle a pu maintenant
les les regards ils sont un petit peu
venu sur elle elle a commencé un petit
peu à dire ce qu'elle AV à dire mais
finalement ça ça a pas vraiment vraiment
changé les taïlandais ont plus de
compassion que ce soit même les
policiers et autres ils ont ils ont pris
ça compassion pour Mina pour Mina que la
France moi personnellement une femme à
l'autre bout de la terre avec son enfant
qui se fait toucher à 12000 km à partir
de ce moment-là ok tu peux pas ramener
quelqu'un tout de suite qui va l'pauler
sur place ça demande une logistique ça
des appels des mails va voir un t il va
t'aider il est agréé par nous il avait
il y avait rien du tout elle était
délivrée à elle-même et c'est de jour en
jour C pire en pire de ça au-delà de ça
moi j'ai appris il y a une dame qui s
était très gentille j'ai pas en dire son
prénom je vais pas lui attirer de
problème elle est thaïlandaise elle vit
ici à quamoui quand elle a parce que
avant de mettre sur Twitter j'avais mis
un poste sur un groupe de français sur
facebook elle m'a dit moi je vais vous
aider je vais pas vous lâcher j'ai des
enfants et elle elle est venue elle a
fait la traduction gratuitement pour moi
une fois euh après ça j'avais un autre
rendez-vous je lui dit est-ce que tu
peux venir m'aider elle m'a dit non je
peux pas alors je lu ai même pas dit
quand et cetera et cette dame là j'ai
mangé avec elle il y a peut-être 2 jours
elle s'est mise à pleurer elle m'a dit
je suis désolée Mina euh quand ils ont
su que je t'avais aidé que j'avais donné
mon nom et tout l'ambassade m'a appelé
pour me dire d'arrêter de t'aider non
mais alors attendez ça para incroyable
Mina vous savez quoi on est un peu pris
par le temps votre appel là ce soir il a
été entendu sur sur C8 Hamza est là
aussi pour vous appuyer en France on
pense aussi à votre petit garçon bien
sûr qui est traumatisé mais vous savez
quoi on va suivre le dossier voilà je
rappelle qu'oré fort de de ce que vous
venez de nous raconter on va demander un
petit peu des des des explications on
vous souhaite beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de courage on vous lâche pas et on va
reprendre de de vos nouvelles très
bientôt courage ne lâchez rien merci
amza d'être venu sur le plateau ce soir
pour pour pour témoigner tout de suite
c'est C
Nouna